Do you want to hear something absolutely
insane? If nobody knows who you are,
it's actually a good thing. And so
imagine this is you and you're here
because you have no followers and of
course you're very sad by that or at
least you think you are. Maybe you're
crying very sad tears, right? And you
don't have this massive audience like
these big celebrities or influencers do.
And I'm just going to explain three
reasons why this will help you win. My
name's Alexi. I'm the founder of
acquisition.com. We make huge sums of
money that are unreasonable. Uh so much
so that I can have unnecessary extra
camera angles like this one and this one
and this one. But I will give you my my
quick disclaimer which is that
everything that I'll share with you um
I'm an experienced business person and
marketer and so these are no way
promises that you will achieve anything
at all. Mostly because most people do
absolutely nothing. That being said,
let's dive in. So number one is that
you're an underdog. So the first and
most important point of being unheard of
is that every position actually has an
advantage. And so for example, let me
tell you a story. So I had a company
called Allen, which I ended up selling
75% of um four years ago, 2021, however
many years ago that was. While I was
working inside of Allen, we had B2B
customers, we had agency owners. And so
an agency owner got on the phone with me
and he actually was serving gym owners.
Now at the time I still owned Gym
Launch, the company that I ended up
selling also in 2021. He said, "I feel
like it's not fair that I have to
compete with you." Now, mind you, I'm
like here trying to help this guy grow
his business, even though he is
technically a competitor of mine by
selling to gym owners. I made this point
to him that I thought was worth making
probably for you, which it doesn't
really matter where you're at in
business. Like I think one, you should
always try and think like an underdog.
If you're in the apparel space, you're
always competing with Nike. And so like
you're an underdog compared to Nike. But
I think the underdog mentality is a
winning mentality because underdogs are
the ones who win ultimately. And the
people who are at the top of the
mountain are the ones who are fat and
happy and end up getting taken over by
the underdog. And so I mean Jeff Basos
talks about this. He says it's always
day one at Amazon is that we want to
they want to keep that mentality. And
part of that reason is why they are so
big is that they still maintain that
flexibility. So I want to hit on some of
these advantages. in talking to this uh
agency owner, he was struggling and he
said, "Everybody who gets on the phone
with me says,"Well, you know, you're not
gym launch and you know, give me your
track record, how long you've been doing
this, things like that." And he was
like, "I just don't really have a good
response." And so I said, "Well, have
you considered that one, when I started
I was in your position?" And so, one,
it's possible. Number two is that your
advantage is that you're not me, right?
So, if we're the biggest person in the
space, which Gym Launch is arguably the
biggest the market leader in that in
that industry, the advantage that I have
as Gym Launch is I'm going to say, "Hey,
this guy Adrian is in his mama's
basement and has no track record. And if
you want Coca-Cola Classic and you want
to know that it's that you have success
stories and there's tons of case studies
and tons of proof of gyms just like
yours seeing this level of success, we
know that our system works. You just
have to run the system, right?" And so
that's fairly compelling. Now, what do
you say in response to that? Well, what
you would say to the prospect is like,
listen, well, you don't want to work
with Gym Launch because to them, you're
just a number. You're never going to
meet Alex. You're never going to even
probably even talk to him. He's not
going to know your name, right? You're
going to get assigned some account rep,
right, that doesn't care either. And
they're just going to be running through
some like checklist with you. Whereas
for me, you're going to have my cell
phone number. If you need anything, you
can call me whenever you want. And it's
actually me. And so who you're really
comparing is not, you know, my company
versus Gym Launch. It's me versus their
rep who they would assign you to. And I
can promise you I'm far more dedicated
to seeing you succeed than they are.
Compelling. Of course, both positions
have advantages. And so you want to play
the cards you're dealt. Only a loser's
perspective that their position in some
way dictates how the end is going to
happen, right? Because one of the
beautiful things about having nothing to
lose is that you also have everything to
gain. And so what it means is that you
also have unlimited shots on goal
because if you miss, you're just back at
zero, which is exactly where you are. So
you have essentially risk-free unlimited
upside, which I think people wildly
underestimate the advantage of the
underdog, which is why in terms of game
theory, they're the most dangerous
player on the board because they can't
lose. And that perspective was
ultimately what got me to even quit my
job in the very beginning was worst case
scenario, I just get my job back. So
that means that like I have risk-free
shots. It's like life giving you a
lottery ticket. The only thing you pay
for is with time, but you still have
unlimited upside every time you scratch
it off. To me, not a bad gig. And to be
clear, I have the portfolio that we have
now and it's all all this money and
success, whatever. But like I had nine
businesses that amounted to almost
nothing before I had my first real big
win. And unless you're Mark Zuckerberg
or you're Jeff Bezos, which is not
common, uh most people fail the first
time and the second and the third. And
sometimes what happens is that the
failures just become less failure. Like
in the beginning like not no one buys
anything. But you do remember building
the logo on the website and thinking
that you had a business but like nothing
happens, right? And then finally you
make your first sale, but you're like
this isn't a real business. Like what's
going on here? Like I exchanged money,
so I guess I technically in business. Do
I have to pay taxes on this now? Like
what happens, right? And then and then
eventually you get to one where you're
like, "Okay, now I'm starting to sell
stuff and make money, but like I'm not
actually making money. I'm making
revenue, but I'm making no profit. I'm
like incurring all this risk and all
this debt in order to get it going." and
you're like still trying to figure it
out and then on like your fourth try
you're like oh what do you know I made a
profit and it took me five years to get
here. every entrepreneur that I know, so
I don't know Zuck and I don't know Jeff
Peso, so you know, unfortunately I'm not
there. But the guys that I know, almost
all of us like failed for a while, like
I don't know anybody who like crushed it
in their first 5 years. Like most people
like basically ate glass and stared into
the abyss to to quote Elon Musk, which
is just existential dread at all points
in time. And the eating glass is the
fact that all you do all day is deal
with problems, which are mostly revolve
around people. And somehow you're
supposed to get work done in between.
So, if you're in that kind of underdog
position, you can pop open the leads
book and I have a chapter that I wrote
on this which is called More Better
News. So, it's 161 and I actually tell
some of this story um that I'm telling
you right now. And one of the things
that most smaller underdogs really no
matter what size you are relatively have
this belief that's false. And so, I want
to kind of crush it for you real quick.
The reason for this ad is I'm throwing
the entrepreneur event of the season and
you're invited.
This is going to be my biggest book
ever. No, not like that. This is going
to be my biggest book. Well, not even
like that. This is going to be my
biggest book ever. Actually, not even
biggest book ever. 100 million Money
Models. And I've been preparing to
release this book to you for over two
years. And at the launch event, August
16th, I'm going to be showing you how to
get more customers to spend more money
with you in less time over and over
again. It's the most valuable skill set
I have. Now, on top of that, come check
this out. I've got five mystery
headliners that have all confirmed
they're going to be there live and
they've never before shared the same
stage and most these people don't speak
publicly. Now, on top of that, I have
four amazing bonuses that are available
to anyone who wants to pre-order a book.
You don't have to because you can
register for free for that. You can show
up for free. You can enjoy all of that
for nothing. But if you want to
pre-order a copy of the book, I got four
bonuses for you. Now, on top of that,
I've got one project that I've been
working on for the last 2 years that
I'll be unveiling live. And I can't tell
you what it is, but I can tell you that
it's better than an NFT. It's less than
a bitcoin and every single person who
shows up live gets one. So if you want
it, click register. I'll see you there
live August 16th. Pre-order a book if
you want. It's going to be awesome.
So number one is that the volatility
that you're experiencing is a result of
inadequate volume. So you're not doing
enough which gives the appearance of
volatility. So let me say it
differently. If you were to sell one
person every like three to five weeks
and you're like, "Yeah, every month I
get like one customer, sometimes I get
two customers." What that really means
is that there's a certain amount of
advertising activity that is occurring,
whether it's you doing it or it's other
people doing it on your behalf or it's
word of mouth, any of those things are
happening. And it takes that much volume
for you to get one new customer. And so
the question we have to ask ourselves is
how can I take the amount of advertising
that's occurring over four weeks to get
me one customer and crush it into one
day so I get one new customer every day.
That's all it is. The volume increasing
volume negates luck and will give you
consistency. The second piece is
understanding where you actually sit
here. Page 168 the size of the pie
fallacy. So the issue is that most small
businesses think that it's like this.
They start advertising on one channel.
They're really happy. Look at this big
smiley face. Okay. Then a competitor
comes in and they start advertising on
the same channel. And then in their
minds they think, "Oh no, I have half of
this market now." And then all of a
sudden two more competitors come in and
now you're like, "Oh no, I have a
quarter of this market. It's shrinking
fast. It's so saturated." But that's a
fallacy. It's a lie. It's an illusion.
This is what it looks like in reality.
So most people see their market as one
method, one platform, one medium.
They're like, "Well, I make Instagram
reels and that's how I get my
customers." So, anybody else who makes
Instagram reels, they're they're in my
market and it's saturated. But the
reality is that there's so many ways to
get customers. You can do warm outreach.
You can do cold outreach. You can post
content. You can run ads. You can have
affiliates. You could have referral
networks. You could have employees doing
this on your behalf. You could have
agencies and head hunters who bring
people in. All of these different
vehicles for advertising. And then
within those vehicles, now you have the
platforms of all those things, right?
So, it's like you're making content on
LinkedIn. You're making content on
Twitter, you're making content on
podcast, you're making content on on tw
on t on on Twitter,
uh Tik Tok, right? For however long it
lasts, right? So, all of these different
platforms. It's like, so really that
little circle that you have is just this
tiny itty bitty circle here and all of
these other circles and all of these
other methods and all of these other
mediums are basically empty. And so, the
reality is no one knows you exist. And
so, the answer is you have to advertise
more. you have to let more more people
know about your stuff. And so the way
that we do this is we do the rule of
100. All right? And so by method, that
means that's page 164. You either do a
100 reachouts a day, cold or warm. You
do a 100 minutes of making content and
post something, which for some reason I
didn't put that in the book. Um, no, I
said release it one per day. Thank God.
All right. But some people hear that
first line and they're like, I'm making
100 minutes of content today. And I'm
like, I haven't seen you post. They're
like, well, I'm still working on it. I'm
like, what are you doing? Post. All
right. And then and then um paid ads is
100 minutes a day of making paid ads. So
that's doing the research, looking at
other hooks, recording, editing, cutting
it, and spending money, right? You got
to spend money. And the amount of money
you spend, I would say per month should
be relative to what you're willing to
pay per customer. Okay? Now, I have an
update to this that I'll share with you
which we learned from the school games
because I help a lot of people who are
starting out. Now, it doesn't matter
whether you're brand new or you're an
experienced business owner. If you start
a new channel, you're still starting at
zero, right? And one of the things that
we added in for at least the content
side was most of the times you'll be
limited by, you know, the amount that
you can make and sometimes even the
amount of DMs that you can do on on a
social platform. But one thing that's
not really limited or less limited is
the amount of comments that you can
leave uh on other people's posts. And so
what you want to do, the goal is to have
the best comment on a post that is
relevant to your avatar. So basically,
it's like all of these posts exist.
They're almost like free ads that you
think are attracting the attention of
your avatar. And so what you want to do
is have the most thoughtful response to
that uh post and then you basically can
like hitch a ride on somebody else's
views and it's totally legal. So like do
that on top of this. And this is for
those you are like I just don't know
what to do. This is what you do. You
reach out to people, you make content,
you run ads. Pick one. And to be clear,
this is Alex's two cents. So this is
this is a personal opinion. Um I don't
really tear people down. That's just I
just don't do that. Um, some people like
make their whole brands on dunking on
other people. I just don't like that
kind of negativity personally, like in
my life or otherwise. Um, you're welcome
to do whatever you want. My
recommendation would be to give people
flowers and, you know, basically give
them props, which is what I think
millennials say. Uh, for when they do a
good job. Sorry, I'm dating myself here.
Uh, flowers, right? Uh, tell them they
did a good job and basically break down
or add to it. Say like, I love all this
and uh, and I think that's a great way.
So instead of saying basically this is
and thinking instead of or thinking. So
my first piece of homework is write what
your advantage is in your current
position. So if you're if you're Nike
and Nike if you do want to respond to
this video, I'm totally okay with it. Uh
but if you're not Nike, right, talk
about the unique angle that you have
compared to the leader in your
marketplace. Because let's be real, the
vast vast majority of people who are
watching this are not the leader because
only one leader and everybody else who's
not the leader is more people than the
one. So the likelihood that you're not
the leader is high. So talk about how
you're different than they are in a way
that is factually correct that they
cannot argue with and drop it in the
comments. I'd love to see them. And
everything that I just talked to you
about those positions is what I would
weave into my sales and my marketing
because the nice thing there is it's
also it's not like claims based. It's
just like these are the facts and this
is the reality of it. And if you ever
want to make more compelling marketing,
the thought that I would give you is
just drill one level deeper. At the
surface level, it's like it's David and
Goliath. But like when you actually
drill down, it's an unfair advantage
because David isn't really competing
against Goliath. It's competing against
Goliath's like kneecap, right? It's like
it's the piece of the larger thing.
There's this amorphous idea of Nike, but
really all you're competing against is
the person who's six levels down who got
hired out of college to make their
social media post for one specific, you
know, person or whatever. That's who you
have to beat. And so, like, the way that
you beat the Roman Empire isn't by
taking the Roman Empire on head on. It's
by tiny little nibbles on the edge of
their kind of perimeter and just working
your way in. And fundamentally, that's
how the barbarians over time, you know,
crunch down on Rome. And so, in this
instance, we are the barbarians. Now,
part two, it's actually much easier to
figure out a smaller business than a
bigger one. And let me explain. So,
you've probably heard the idea that if
you have a boat, right, it's much easier
to turn a dinghy than it is to turn the
Titanic. Well, obviously you can't turn
the Titanic because they dead. Just
kidding. The boat's dead. the people
might still be alive. I have no idea.
Um, and I don't know if they had smoke
stacks, but let's just pretend this is
the Titanic before they had this big
hole and everyone died. Okay? And so,
and so the idea is it's much easier and
more nimble to move a small boat. Now,
let me give you the actual math. So,
this is cute, but let me tell you the
actual business behind this. We use a
term that we call nail it then scale it.
All right? And it's really nail it in
order to scale it. And the problem is
most people learn how to advertise. They
learn how to sell a little bit and then
think, "Oh, I just need to do more of
that." But here's the problem with that.
Until you find out what the compounding
vehicle is within your business, you're
bound to plateau. And so, I've done this
example before, but I think it's so
powerful that it's worth repeating. All
right? So, let's say that you have
company A and company B. All right? And
both of them sell 100 people per year.
Okay? So, 100 new customers per year.
Sorry, A sells 100 per year. B sells 100
the first year, 200 the second year, 300
the third year. Well, which company
would you rather have at face value?
You'd think, "Oh, I'd rather have B."
But wait, there's more. Let's say
company B loses 100 customers every year
because they're not that good at what
they do or they don't have a very good
model. And so that means that next year
they lose 200 and next year lose 300.
Now, let's say company A keeps 100% of
their customers. So, year two, they
actually have 200 customers and year
three they have 300 customers. They have
the original 200 plus this 100. So, now
it's 300 in total. So, both of these
look like they're 300
sales per year businesses. But which of
these would you now rather have? This
guy, because the margins are going to be
better because you don't have to pay to
acquire all of these extra customers.
They had to pay to acquire 600
customers, right?
This one only had to pay to acquire 300.
All of that added cost drops straight to
the bottom line. But on top of that,
this is a business that literally will
always keep growing. If you think about
it, every year they you could sell
another 100 customers and it would just
keep growing. This business next year,
if you sell another 300, the only way to
grow is to sell 400 customers next year
just to keep up with a and I can promise
you one of the laws of nature is that
advertising to acquire customers only
becomes more expensive in time because
you are going out to colder and colder
audiences that are less and less of a
fit. You're you're not getting the early
adopters. You're actually getting the
lagards and the late adopters. And so it
costs you more to reach them. They're
harder to sell. They're more price
sensitive. like it has all the negative
things. And so this is common when
companies look that are bigger. If
they're looking to exit, the acquirers,
any who's an investor is going to look
at this and say, how much runway is
there that's left? And is there a way
that we want at the very least can
maintain the customers we have and
ideally have some sort of vehicle inside
of it that allows those customers to
bring us more customers. And so imagine
that let's say you're here and then you
watch this video. And unfortunately,
I've had a lot of business owners who
watch my stuff like realize this is that
they're like, "Oh no, I'm this business
and I'm selling 300 people every year
and I'm losing 300 people every year.
Well, what do I do now?" It's tough
because you're in a rock in a hard place
scenario. And this is why it's so
important to nail it, then scale it. And
so, you just want to advertise and sell
enough so that you can figure out what
is required in order to keep customers,
keep them happy, keep them referring,
keep them paying. If you can't figure
that out, there's basically no point to
scaling. it's going to get more and more
expensive. Your margins are going to get
thinner and it will feel more volatile
because you probably ri rely almost
exclusively on paid ads. That's tough.
And so having a different way to think
about it, which is you want to get the
foundational unit right. Once you get
that right, everything else gets much
easier. You know, I'm a I'm a huge
consumer of software startup, you know,
founders. And one of the things that
they talk about a lot is it's so much
better to just build your product or
build your service for a 100 people to
absolutely love you than to have a
million people who kind of like you. I
think part of this is that it's very
difficult to to build something for the
amorphice for like the faceless masses.
But it's much easier to build something
for a specific person of which there
happen to be many and many of those
people. And so I think getting really
crystal clear this is why having like an
ICP or customer avatar whatever you want
to call it um some sort and you can like
name them. It's like this is Jenny. this
is our customer. She has three kids and
she, you know, wants to lose weight or
whatever it is, right? Would Jenny like
this? Like, what would Jenny think about
this? Right? And some of the best
companies that I've seen from a product
and branding perspective always
basically have Jenny sitting at the
table or their customer avatar and
they're like, "Well, what do you think
Jenny thinks about this?" Right? And
that's what allows them to make the best
long-term decisions for both the
customer and the brand. Like, for the
love of God, if the economics that you
have when you're small aren't amazing,
they're not going to get better when you
get bigger. And so if you're like,
"Okay, that's great, Alex, but how do I
tactically improve my offer or like my
offering to the marketplace?" So inside
the offer book, I talk about this um
which is creating your grand slam offer
part one and two, which is basically the
problems and solutions. And so I think
one of the best exercises that anyone
can do with their team is and if it's if
you're just the team, then it's just
you, right? Is to sit down and say,
let's write down what here I'll walk
through I'll walk I'll walk you through
it. So the first thing we're going to
say is what's the dream, right? What
does Jenny want? what is what is her big
outcome that she wants to have happen.
Okay, now that we define that, we want
to be as crystal clear about that as we
possibly can. It also feeds in the
messaging, sales scripts, copy, etc. The
second thing is we're going to talk
about what are the problems. What are
all the things that are getting in the
way of her getting her dream of
accomplishing what she wants to
accomplish? And we want to be as again
as specific as possible here. Now,
typically there's really one big dream,
right? But there's many problems that
get in the way of that dream, right?
It's very simple to just say, "Oh, I
just want a six-pack." That's a dream,
right? But what are all the things that
are preventing you from uh getting your
six-pack? It's probably like you don't
know how to cook food. You don't know
how to grocery shop. You don't know how
to weigh yourself. You don't know how to
count calories. You don't know how to
lift weights. You don't have time to go
to the gym. You don't have you have to
make different food for you as you do
for your spouse. Like there's almost
unlimited problems that can that can
manifest. And all you have to do is ask
somebody who's give just give listen to
their excuses. Those that's what the
problems are going to be. All right. Now
once you have the problems what I want
you to do and this is a mental exercise
is you list them
as solutions.
So you take so after you have all the
problems you're then going to list them
as solutions. So the solution is going
to have two parts to it. One is you want
to have some sort of name around it
that's like okay you don't know how to
cook food. So we have our you don't have
to cook food system. All right. Now
underneath of that we're going to have
every possible way that we can think of
and this is probably the most creative
fun part right. going to list every
possible creative way that you could
solve it. And I'm saying like you can't
think about cost. You you you have to be
purely brainstorm. And so by the way,
fun rule for brainstorming is that you
never say no. You just add to things.
You say that's amazing. And so it's not
it's a lot of and thinking, not or
thinking. There's a lot of good ideas
are on the third or fourth iteration.
All right? And so for example, with this
meal thing, I could myself drive to
their house and I could cook their food
for them. I could do that, right? Like
let's write it down. What else could we
do? We could hire a chef to do that.
Okay, cool. What else could we do? Maybe
we hire chef for lots of people. Okay,
that's kind of interesting. Oh, what
else could we do? We could do a grocery
store where we actually take them
shopping. Okay, well, could we do a
recorded version of that? We could do a
recorded version of that, too. Right?
And so all the things you think about
all the different ways you could solve
it. When you think about this, you're
like, "Wow, there's like 20 ways I could
solve this problem, right? Which then
leads you to step four, which is I call
the trim and stack." And this is
probably the most businessoriented part
of the five steps. All right? which is
you have this big list and you say,
"Okay, if we were to rate these on which
of these are very high value and which
of these are low cost,
we want the ones that are super high
value, super low cost to be our first
priority. Now, the second bucket, and
this is something that I've probably
changed that's that might be a little
different than uh what I have in the
books. This is a little bit of an update
is I am more okay with what about some
things that are incredibly high value
that have some cost because a lot of
people immediately go to zero cost
solutions because they want to just have
something that cost nothing. The thing
is is it's very crowded in the zerocost
solution market but you know what's not
that crowded the little bit of cost
solution or the medium cost solution but
very high value. And so the thing is is
that this process is an unconstrained
ideiation process. And the reason for
that is we have yet to determine our
price. And so you might be like, well, I
can't drive out to their house. Could
you for a million dollars? Probably.
Well, then it's not off the board yet,
right? So we just want to think what is
the most valuable combination of these
things. Then we go to step five and we
say this is now our valuable thing, our
valuable grand slam offer.
for
whatever amount of money that you want
to charge that makes sense relative to
your trim and stack. And this process,
I'm telling you, if you're like, "Man,
my customers aren't in love with my
product yet." Then build this out. And
here's the thing.
In the next 60 seconds, I'm going to
show you the system that's responsible
for the vast majority of my material
success. And inside this, I'm doing this
at the live launch event. I'm going to
show you how to get customers to spend
more money with you in less time over
and over again. But that's not all. On
top of that, there's going to be four
amazing bonuses that are available to
anyone who wants to pre-order before the
event. And on top of that, I've got one
secret project that I've been working on
for over two years that I'm going to be
releasing live at the event itself. Now,
I can't tell you what it is yet, but I
can tell you that it's better than an
NFT, and it's less than a Bitcoin, and
every single person who shows up live
gets one. But you got to be there August
16th. So, click register, and I'll see
you there live.
It's much easier and this is unfortunate
but it's it's much easier to promise
these things than it is to deliver them.
And so the reason that I emphasize the
nailed and scaled is that if you do have
multiple components to your service,
your product that you want to deliver
and have this be incredibly valuable
thing, this is very compelling when you
present it to somebody, which is why you
can raise your prices, you can make more
profit, you can market better, can sell
better when you follow this framework.
But if you can't deliver, you don't want
to scale it yet. you want to keep
working on it. And the reality is that
it's going to take a lot longer than you
think. Like I it's like this has just
been a very hard lesson learned for me
is that what you think should take you
six weeks, often times six takes six
months, sometimes a year. And so what
what you realize the longer you do
business is that there are just far
fewer things, fewer new things that you
can take on than you really think. And
so there's always going to be an issue
with translating these things to your
team so that they can actually execute.
and forget about new people coming in
who haven't even gone through this
process. They're just adopting this
final solution, but they don't know how
you got here and how you derived it. And
so being more patient about the idea and
I'll I'll give you I'll give you a pro
tip. This is a little side quest for
you. So in any given function, let's say
that this is your baseline of
performance. All right. Now, whenever
you change anything, in my experience,
you get about a 20% decrease in
performance immediately. All right? So
if you change a sales script, you get a
decrease in performance. You change your
your ad copy, you're going to decrease
in performance often time. change your
landing page, most times the page that
you had probably was working. And so
something that's not that has a lower
likelihood of succeeding than something
that is more of that, right? And so a
lot of times when you make a change, and
this is especially operational changes
more so than anything else, often times
you get a decrease or decrement in
performance. And so if I know that I'm
guaranteed to have this 20% decrease,
then it means that I need to make
changes that I have a very strong idea
that they're going to have at least a
20% increase effect. And so the result
of this line of thinking which has made
me a significantly better entrepreneur
this is a huge breakthrough for me is
that number one some things will never
get fixed and that means that some
things are like man this could be 5%
better the cost of the change if you are
constantly changing things because
here's the thing is you're like well
it's still I would I'd be willing to
give the 20 to four months from now have
that you know return to baseline and
then get the 5% improvement. Yeah, but
that assumes that you're going to change
nothing else in that f fourmonth period,
but you might be an add entrepreneur and
you might just change it, which means
that you're actually permanently kind of
sitting at this 20% decrease in
performance because you've never given
anyone a chance to get good at their
job. You're always changing And so
I traditionally will overindex now on
stability because we get consistent
improvements in performance across the
team because people just get better at
their job, right? And then if I really
think that something's worth changing,
it better be north of 20%. And so it's
like, man, I keep doing the math, like I
think this is like a 30 to 50% boost for
us. If that's the case, then it's
probably worth the bet. But most of the
small changes that I used to mess around
with my company where I like, oh no, I'm
Steve Jobs. Every detail has to be
there. Like if you're building a
physical product that is manufactured,
that's different. If you're building
software one times change different in a
service business if you're changing
process that people have to execute very
tough make sure that it's worth it and
to bring this whole offer stack idea
back to being an underdog. If you do
this when you have zillions of customers
way harder than if you just have a
handful because you can change the back
like you can be more nimble and so the
smaller your team is the more agile
they'll be the less this decrement in
performance will be as a result. If it's
just you, I mean, you don't need to
communicate as anyone. You could just
change, right? And so, like, again,
think about that as that natural
extreme. On one side, it's just you. So,
there's basically no change in or
decrease in performance. Now, you have
to learn stuff, but you'll learn it
quickly, right? But if you have to
translate it to a 50 person team, it's
like you better be darn sure that it's
good and worth it. And so, this is
another advantage that you have of being
smaller. So, nail it first so that
you're not going to have to change this
later because it's going to be costly.
And so the third big reason that there's
a huge advantage of being an underdog is
that your competition changes over time.
Let me kind of break this down for you.
So in the beginning, the big
competition, you can maybe make the
argument this one's always there, right?
Uh is you. You are the competitor,
right? Like you have to get yourself off
the couch. Like the person you're
competing against this like lazy version
of you, version of you that you think
you need to be better than, right? Now,
let's say that you're like, you know
what? I finally believe that I could do
this. Okay. Well, who who's the next big
person that you're going to have to have
to face? It's going to be your family
and your friends. Because now some of
you guys have amazingly supportive
friends and family. And I am so grateful
for you. But for everybody else, uh, a
lot of those people aren't going to
believe you. They're not going to
believe in you. They're not going to
believe in your idea. Um, and they'll
say sometimes tonight remarks. Sometimes
they'll scoff at the trade-offs that
you're willing to make, right? Like
you're like, "Well, I can't go to that
event because I need to keep working on
this and then all of a sudden now you're
costing them, right? Because the thing
is is that fundamentally they have this
relationship with you and it's based on
these expectations and you're saying,
you know what, I'm changing the
expectations of our relationship. And
most people don't like when things
change. And the reality is that like
like I'd say that in the earliest part
of my career, this was by far the
biggest part that was painful is the
friends that you that you move on from
um because you say, "Hey, this is the
terms of our new, you know, new
relationship, if you want to call it
that way." And they be like, "Well, I
don't agree to those terms." And you're
like, "Well, then I guess you can't
really be here anymore." It's kind of
tough because the thing is is like I've
seen a lot of entrepreneurs like they
will just say you know what I would
rather have these friends than my dream
and if that's you amazing you won. You
made a decision. But I would just advise
you to say like is it really worth it?
And I would say that a lot of people
that I've had in my life um have come
and gone and I've been very grateful for
the work that I've been willing to do.
That's a you know Alex one thing uh you
can do whatever you want and I don't
know anything. I have three. I do have
three cameras, though. So, you know,
just saying. All right. So, what's the
next competitor? So, now the next one is
going to be employees. Now, it's not
necessarily that you're going to be
employees. So, think of these more as
like bosses you have to face that you
have to get over. And these never go
away. So, it's like they add on top of
each other. You're still going to have
to conquer yourself at every level.
You're still going to have new pressures
from friends and family at every level.
Now, here now, you got to sell employees
on your dream. You have to recruit
really smart people because if you want
to do something good, you're going to
you're going to need help. All right?
Like uh there's an old African proverb
that I love which is if you want to go
fast go alone. If you want to go far go
together. Um and I think big things are
accomplished with teams because
fundamentally like anything that's
really big and worth doing takes a
tremendous amount of expertise and it
takes time to to learn all these
different skills. And so like you can't
live 20 lifetimes. And so like no matter
how smart you are, it's it's you have a
lot more leverage finding people who are
exceptional at these things and just
bringing them in. So like oh I'm going
to leverage this 20 years that they
already spent there. I don't have to
spend those 20 years. I have all that
experience and skill set. I'll just
bring them on in. Right now, the next
level that ends up coming up and this is
the bigger businesses will will hear me
in the room. Uh you're going to have
market place changes because now you're
big enough um where like markets do move
you right when you're really really
small like basically like it doesn't
matter how small the industry is. If
you're trying to make $100,000 a year,
you can do it because the industry is
probably if it is an actual industry is
going to be significantly larger than
$100,000, right? In terms of revenue.
And so it's almost an inconsequential
amount of money. Not saying to you as a
person, but to to like in general for a
marketplace, it's not a lot of money.
And so, uh, as you get bigger, like if a
market shrinks by 20% and you're a huge
part of that market, like that will
affect you, right? And also to the same
degree, as you make more money, uh,
regulators begin to target you and try
and find things that you are not being
compliant for. Like Elon talks about
this. Now, this is not a political
comment. I'm just saying like if you
look at Amazon, look at Fortnite, look
at Reebok, uh just in the last year, all
of them been hit with uh FTC suits
around something that's not compliant.
And so I will just say one thing on this
then I'll move on which is fundamentally
when 100% of businesses are not obeying
some law then there's probably a deeper
question which is is the law just and
who are the ones who are making these
laws and are these people people who are
qualified to make them based on their
business experience? And so I want to be
clear, I think there's always uh there's
important, you know, it's important to
have rules of the game in order to play
any game. Um but I do also subscribe to
Elon's perspective of like if there are
too many referees on the field, you
can't play the game at all. And so but
these are these are facts of life. And
so to loop this to what I was talking
about at the beginning, which is the
advantage they have as an underdog is
you don't need to worry about all these
other things yet. And these things are
coming, but you don't have to worry
about it yet because like you're not big
enough for a regulator to give a
about you honestly, right? like your
friends and family like maybe you're
just getting started. And so these are
things that are coming. The competitors
will change in their sophistication and
in the pressure that you're exposed to
and you just got to stand tall and deal
with it. But as an underdog, you're like
not my problem right now. I just got to
focus what's in front of me. And so
that's the advantage that you have. And
part of the difficulty with the friends
and family and sometimes customers is
well, I'll just tell you a story that I
think will illustrate it. So, I wrote
this narrative when I was a gym owner
when I was probably 23 24 years old.
Now, I I like writing. I was a I got a a
creative writing scholarship back in the
day. I ended up not taking it. Um but uh
I like writing. I was head of the the
creative literary magazine in in high
school and something I enjoyed. So, I
wrote this this article basically or
essay called um everyone believes in the
American dream until it comes true. I
was struggling with this difficulty of
my reality which was that you know when
I started out in the gym which was my
first business uh I didn't have enough
money for two rents and so I had saved
up all my money for two years to start
the gym and I didn't have enough money
for rent so I just slept at the gym
which I was fine with and you know
customers basically could figure out
because they could see my pillow in the
corner like they kind of got what was
going on and they were like good for you
for you know pursuing your dream like
that's awesome like keep at it and then
like the gym started to grow right it
started you know started to fill up. We
started I started to be able to hire
employees and you know probably nine
months later or a year later you know
I'd come in and at this point I have a
manager for location and it kind of runs
not without me but like I owned it more
than me running you know working inside
of it and I'd show up and then like you
know the clients would be like ah boss
man's here you know and I remember being
like wait I like you guys said that you
were rooting for me to pursue my dream
and now that I've accomplished my dream
you guys make snide remarks at me And it
was, you know, I I've said this before,
but it was the first time that I
realized that people want you to do
well, just not better than them. As you
continue to achieve, you will see that
in the vast majority of people. Now, I
believe that special friends exist who
truly want you to win. And if you have
those people, like, hold them close
because most people aren't like that. Uh
most people will be happy either overtly
or more likely subconsciously or you
know under the under the you know under
the surface when you lose they're happy
because it makes them feel better about
the things they didn't take on the risk
they didn't take and so it's tough
business isn't for the faint of heart
but at the same time neither is life and
so I think like everything everything is
hard and I think that the only real flaw
in the system is that we have a belief
that it shouldn't be and that if we
somehow change our conditions, it will
get easier. And it basically just never
does. And I think that's been something
that's like helped me kind of get
through my like woe is me wallowing
moments that I have, which is like if I
had a job that I wasn't satisfied with,
I would be unhappy. If I have if I have,
you know, stressors of day-to-day
business that occur like that also can
make me unhappy. Now, of course, we make
the argument nothing makes you happy or
unhappy. Um, but I am human probably
like you and I have things that
definitely have I have better days and
worse days. And I think that more or
less across all of these situations, I
have rem more or less stayed the same,
right? Like I think there are things
that uh money buys you that make life
more convenient. And it's definitely one
of those things that uh you never
believe people until you have it. So,
I'm not going to try and dissuade you
from doing it. My whole channel is about
helping you grow your business. Um, but
I think that it helped me get over a lot
of stress in thinking that this should
not be this way. Like just like what
what demand of the universe am I making
that isn't true? Business should be
easy. It should feel better. Uh, it
shouldn't be this stressful. Like it
shouldn't have this many people
problems. And also comparing it to the
alternative which also has problems. And
so I think a lot of times we get in this
really negative spiral as business
owners, which is we compare ourselves.
We look at the we look at the grass on
the other side of the field, but we
don't know that it's lined with manure,
right? That's what makes it grow. And I
think I I try to remind myself of that.
Like whenever there's a green pasture,
it's like it's built on.
And so that helps me just say like,
okay, I just don't know what the is on
the other side, but it's there. And that
kind of gets me, you know, kind of back
in the saddle and focused. And so I will
I will wrap with this which is that if
you were an underdog, you have
advantages. Every position has an
advantage. You have to nail it and then
you scale it. And be grateful that the
competitor that you're competing against
right now is smaller because they only
get bigger and stronger as you get
bigger and stronger. So if you're a
business owner, I uh just started doing
these real business breakdowns of
business owners that actually have come
to our headquarters. um and uh from the
audience, some of you guys, uh and I'll
spend an hour or two with them and
basically break down what they need to
do to scale their business at a super
tactical level. I think it's some of the
best stuff that we're putting out. I'm
super proud of it, very excited about.
Go check the video out, watch it, enjoy
it, and uh let me